okay I'm gonna recreate your reaction to
being cast at celebration it was it was
a three-act event react play yeah it was
like oh thank you thank you pass out but
can you walk me through actually finding
out that you were cast as the
Mandalorian well I got a call and the
the actual words were Jon Favreau wants
to talk to you about something Star Wars
and so I said absolutely and I went out
to meet him at his offices in Playa
Vista and he invited me into a room
where he introduced me to Dave Filoni
and in this room it was wall-to-wall
immaculate illustrations of this series
which is everything Star Wars all the
background players at the bar all the
little creatures that got like you know
a second of film time in the movies were
all these sort of central powerful
characters and all this imagery and at
the center of it all was this Boba Fett
like character called the Mandalorian
and so being a Star Wars fan myself I
was like oh what's this and oh I
remember that and what are you gonna do
here and what do you want me to do what
creature do you want me to play what
robot do I have to audition what's the
story
and they looked confused and basically
like pointed to the it's incredible its
silhouette of the Mandalorian he said
you're the you're the Mandalorian so
that's why I had this way I sort of died
inside of joy how could you not I mean u
s-- mentioned your Star Wars fans so
what's your earliest Star Wars memory do
you remember like I saw Star Wars
I saw Episode four in the movie theater
I was very young so I I don't remember
the experience of being in the theater
for it as well as I do the Empire
Strikes Back which is
burned into my childhood imagination and
I remember like three attempts to get
tickets for Return of the Jedi and and
getting my heart broken every time
because it was sold out and then finally
getting the tickets and literally you
know like staring at the poster being
like I'm finally seeing this movie so it
was it was highly you know present in my
childhood all the toys you know and and
all the stories yeah and now you're in
it and now I'm in it it's weird leaning
the series
[Music]